this is a story I wish I didn't have to
react to I did send a DI pi to my mom
what oh you know when you send the text
like no no no now I will tell you at
first I was really upset but then I
started to think if I was going to send
an accidental big pick any my family I'm
glad it was my
mom it's just wrong and by the way that
coming out of my mouth that's needs an
explanation here it is look it's not
just because I like weird [__] which I
do there not a whole lot weirder than
sending a dick pick to your mom but the
real reason I was glad I sent it to my
mom I mean there's a lot of things
funnier than sending a dickpick to your
mom she's such a supportive
person
you I thought the worst I was going to
get back is theck like that looks great
honey or something like that in what
world is your mom reacting to your own
to your dickpick of her son and saying
that look looks great honey she
ghosted no text for like 4 hours y I
almost sent her a text like are we going
talk about my dick or
what there's a reason why I'm with
Grandma on this
one and then about the 4 Hour Mark I
just got this text from
her and it was the worst text I could
have gotten I didn't know at the time it
was the worst text h like this the worst
text she could have sent she just sent a
text back at said
what is
that you just got obliterated by your
own
mother I couldn't even imagine what it
would look like for her to not know what
it is like o I'm just thinking of like
gross like saggy sausage link that's the
only thing that comes to mind and I was
like I almost texted my dad like send me
a picture of your dick right now let's
see what that are ours that different
are you packing a hammer like what the
[__] is going on that I mom doesn't know
what my dick looks like a ridiculous